sketch the graphs of the following
linear equations still linear prisons
yeah now what was chosen was why now
before I start off on this one
I want you to look at all six of the
questions under this heading okay
in fact I'm just gonna write all of them
so we can all compare them you'd have to
write note that but as well as this one
I have this all of these things these
are not revision and they are covered
under the same idea okay now just have a
look at these six graphs with me
wash I should say if you were listening
about 30 seconds ago you would know yes
I know these are the six questions
underneath question three okay now I
want you to look at them with me and try
to work out like why are these group
together what do they all have in common
okay they all they all do have an X in
common
but you know what these also have X's in
common all right what is it about these
these six that are in common among these
six but not in others yeah okay let's
just say that again because that's
really important right these numbers
Sascha's they're these equations they're
all similar because it's just something
times X and then that's it that's it
it's just like 2/3 times X or 5 times X
or a heart right you get the idea all
these other ones they've got extra
numbers flying around okay now that
actually needs something it means that
all of these things are actually adding
zero record now you're like what's the
big deal why even bother writing adding
zero because it doesn't change it right
that's why it's not written okay but
think back to this first question we do
here right there's this number at the
front of the X what's that mean again
it's gradient okay so you got a whole
bunch of gradients then you know the
second number what's the second number
it's it's the Y
here was negative eight but over here
all six of them the wiper sets up all
zero right so in fact even though you
know I'm cheating a little bit you guys
asked me to draw 80 we can actually draw
all six of these on the same ground
watch let's do it now let's draw up a
set of axes make it reasonably bigger
than the other ones because um we're
gonna put six graphs on it so it's gonna
get a little crowded
okay now the y-intercepts for all of
these are all zero so I yeah draw
opposite axes okay now if all of them
have the same y-intercept 0 that means
they all pass through there every single
one of them right so they all intersect
the fancy word for this is they're all
concurrent at that point they all pass
so it's like a giant crazy intersection
okay you [ __ ] that up
you thought that County Drive around
that was bad this is gonna be a lot
worse so let's start with well let's
start with the one that you guys get 2/3
X ok now in order to draw this out I
want you to get a ruler out let's do
this let's do this as accurately as we
can this number you'd already told me it
was the gradient right gradient is rise
over run rise over run so we're going to
go up 2 units or what get your rule
about right and I want you to measure up
two centimeters one two so that's the
rise and then we're gonna run three
units so I want you to measure three
centimeters one two three okay so there
that point there that'll be two up three
across rise run and now you can join
that guy on that's fine okay
let's label it you'll see why in a
second why labeling on grass just so
ever important Jake have you gonna ask a
question did you want to
yeah it does help us fairly it's very
hot
all right now there's the first one good
done okay let's have a look at the next
one white goes to X right now that's
really 2 over 1 so you got the flies in
the run they're still okay so the rise
is 2 and the run is 1 so you go up 1 2
and then your run is 1 so now you're
here okay so I'm going to join up these
two dots let's see how I go yes I will
okay so what just happened I went from
this graph and I started to look at the
next graph because because this one it's
done yeah so now look at this one it
still goes through the same y-intercept
but its gradient is 2 so it goes up to
an across one ok so now this one's done
okay what about this one negative 3
minus 3 X graph that it goes it goes
down doesn't it the rise rise is
negative 3 sir
so it gets your rule right and go 1 2 3
but in the downward direction and then
the run is 1 so now this is the point
I'm going to go through and I can join
these up it's a bit harder just going
just barely okay so this line I just
drew starts the curve a little bit
that's minus 3x done no that's ok I did
plus 0 to illustrate the fact that all
over have the same y-intercept
ok because it's not as obvious but it's
not written there 5 X now before I do
this before I put it on there
why don't you expect 5x to be hmm now
you know that it's going to be
increasing up towards the right so
that's good
but you also know for instance you
should compare this one at this one
right you have 2x you know 5x which
one's steep up 5x is thing because 5 is
a gradient is bigger than 2 is a
gradient so there's 2 X so it's gonna be
like this but Eve
right so the grain is 5 so you got 1 2 3
4 5 and then you go across one
alright that's really steep isn't very
so you try your best you'll you'll be
fine with a ruler I think okay we go
that's that steepest what I've got there
y equals 5x because really that five is
a five over one so rise over run well
you have a look at the different omens
you've got you meet over one right room
is done I'm going to do is a bit quicker
because I think you're saying to get the
idea 1/2 X right rise is one right is
two up one across - so it's going to be
there I'm going to draw that across why
have you got one because the rise is 101
is - yeah that's right that's right and
then my last one minus five over two so
our rise is -5 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 and
then the run is 2
let's see this is tricky it should be
it's very close to this one now by the
way I don't know if you heard me say
that this one here I just drew - five
minute 2x I knew I knew that it was
going to be very close to minus 3x can
you see why - private sure that's an
improper fraction what would you write
as as a mixed in you know yeah yeah
that's right - the tuna ha and of course
- 2 and 1/2 is very close to minus 3/2
1/2 3 they're only off by a little bit
and that's why the Lions aren't only off
by a little bit okay
so now you can see all these lines all
six of them they all pass through the
origin because they all have the same
why innocent what changes is the
gradient okay